hey guys it's Thursday we're only two
days away from the start of a three 2017
I need is getting exciting we'll be
bringing you all the latest news
features reveals and everything you
could possibly want to know from e3 so
be sure to stay tuned to us and don't
forget to grab the game spot now app on
iOS and Android so you can get the top
ten news stories of the day delivered
right to your phone but for now here's
what's been going on today last month I
had to tell you that Shenmue 3 would not
be appearing at 83 and now I have to
tell you that it's actually been delayed
for a while yes director Yu Suzuki
posted an update to Kickstarter backers
where he explained by utilizing new
technologies we've been able to discover
new possibilities and expressions in
many ways the game has become bigger and
more beautiful than I initially expected
we do however need more time to deliver
the game to you
we're moving ahead with a plan to
release the game in the second half of
2018 Shenmue 3 and its Kickstarter was
revealed at Sony's e3 conference in 2015
the campaign pulled in over 6.3 million
bucks from almost 70,000 backers and
both of those are very big numbers back
to you Dan thanks Dan all eyes are on
Microsoft as we get ever closer to the
Xbox project Scorpio reveal and just
yesterday the company trademarked a new
s logo design check it out Oh fancy
the trademark application was spotted by
the verge and covers video game console
to be used with an external display
screen or monitor and video game
interactive remote control units so it
could be for a new or updated console
this follows the company's trademarking
of direct reality earlier this week to
cover video game software and computer
software for holographic applications
which might be a hint of the company's
intention to jump into the VR race or
maybe a rebrand for the existing
hololens Xbox boss Phil Spencer also
confirmed today that there III briefing
will be longer than the usual 19 minutes
to show off more games on top of that
Xbox corporate VP Mike Ybarra tweeted
that he is traveling with the xbox
Scorpio chip in hand which he dubbed the
monster if you're as anxious to find out
what's going down with project Scorpio
as we are the Xbox briefing kicks off at
2 p.m. Pt
this Sunday in things that annoy me if
you're excited for cyberpunk 2077 from
setup right red you might need to be
purple Blake's of mine someone has
hacked the developer and is holding some
design documents of the gang to ransom
set a proyect red released a statement
on Twitter saying an individual or
individuals have informed them that they
are in possession of several of the
developer's internal files specifically
older design documents for cyberpunk
2077 the statement goes on to say that a
ransom demand has been made to keep the
files from going public
sounds like Sitapur eggs aren't
interested in negotiating with hacker
terrorists though as the developer has
said they won't be paying the ransom and
has informed the appropriate authorities
the files are apparently quote
unrepresentative of the current vision
of the game instead of Project red has
asked that if you're excited for
cyberpunk 2077 it would be best to avoid
any information not coming directly from
the developer apart from the general
shittiness of what these hackers have
done this one really gets to me because
setup reacts have always gone so far out
of its way to be pro-consumer and
support what it's what it's wants
fingers crossed this one doesn't impact
them too much that's everything we have
for you today do enjoy the rest of your
day we'll have the top 5 stories of the
whole week all ready to go for you
tomorrow so come see us again then